when it comes to mental health in the
u.s. there's a lot of talk and little
action many fault mental illness for
things like mass shootings even though
most mentally ill are not violent but
few point out that every year close to
44 million adults will experience a
mental illness and less than half will
receive care and 40% of those with
severe mental illnesses like
schizophrenia or bipolar disorder won't
get the help they need
here are 5 ways the mental health care
system is in crisis compared to 50 years
ago there are far fewer people in mental
institutions today which sounds like a
good thing when you think about mental
institutions you think about Girl
Interrupted or One Flew Over the
Cuckoo's Nest scary places with mean
staff and catatonic patients unsanitary
inhumane lobotomies which was true
according to a bunch of expose on mental
hospitals back in the day public outrage
combined with the first effective
anti-psychotic drug put politicians on a
path of reform so in 1963 JFK signed the
Community Mental Health Act which
accelerated what's known as
deinstitutionalization that means
institutions were closed and patients
move back into their communities there
they were supposed to get care in newly
funded community mental health centers
the idea was to create a less
restrictive setting and protect patients
civil rights good plan but after all
these years these community mental
health centers still have never been
fully funded and the program has fallen
by the wayside and a lot of people who
were released never got the services
they needed then in 1988 President
Reagan's / federal mental health
spending by 25 percent so where do
people end up
for a lot of them jail in 2012 there
were 10 times as many mentally ill
people in prisons and jails than in
state hospitals and close to 400,000
adults with untreated mental illness are
in jails in effect prisons are the new
mental institutions which according to
the National Alliance on Mental Illness
wouldn't be the case if there were
better services there also aren't enough
people to help there are fewer
psychiatric professionals to go around
compared to other healthcare
professionals close to 90 million
Americans live in areas with a shortage
of mental health care providers which
can mean long waits for treatment or
long distances to travel or there just
are no options period because if you
really needed help and inpatient care
the US has only 28% of the beds needed
and even if you find the perfect doctor
your insurance might not cover your
treatment plan
insurance companies used to be able to
charge higher co-pays for psychiatric
care than for other medical treatments
and limit the number of visits all the
way up until 2008 when the mental health
parity and addiction Act forced insurers
to cover mental illness equally but
experts say insurers are still finding
loopholes and what about all those
people who didn't get access before the
law changed you might go see your
regular doctor once a year but if you
need to see a psychiatrist once a week
those co-pays add up especially when
you're on a tight budget new rules are
not cost is a real barrier and
non-traditional treatments like
acupuncture often aren't covered of
course in order for any treatment to
work patients have to seek it out and
the stigma against mental illness can
hold people back we often treat mental
illness as dangerous or as a character
flaw and the fear of being ostracized or
institutionalized is real that's why
admitting you need help is the first
challenge and the second is actually
getting it so isn't it time we have a
conversation about mental health that
actually leads somewhere instead of just
throwing up our hands